15 شهرا من الصمود بررت سخاء الغرب
واستثماره في نصر عسكري اوكراني غير مشروط
وبعد كل مرحله تلتهم فيها الحرب المزيد من
المال والسلاح يطالب داعم كيف بجرعه امل
اخرى
بحلول الربيع الموعود تحالفت نجاحات الامس
في خاركيف وكيف مع ضغط الحلفاء من اجل دفع
الجيش الاوكراني نحو معركه حاسمه اركان
الهجوم المضاد اكتملت الاف الاوكرانيين
عادوا الى بلادهم مسلحين بفلسفه النيتو
ومعداته اما اوحال الشرق فقد جفت بحلول
الربيع المبكر على الورق تمتلك اوكرانيا
ما يكفي لخوض حرب الاسترجاع غير ان للواقع
احكامه
الامل المتعلقه بهجومنا المضاد تم تضخيمها
الجميع يتوقع شيئا عظيما مما قد يتسبب
بخيبه امل كبيره
واقعيه على حساب معنويات الجيش لم يبحث
ريزنكوف كثيرا ليجد ما يبررها
1200 كم من الجبهه لم تعد اراضي مفتوحه
وروسيا شيدت خط دفاع يمتد عبر حدودها التي
رسمتها
اما الهجوم فهو مغامره تختلف عن الدفاع
داخل المدن ووراء التحصينات حشدت موسكو
هذه المره نصف مليون جندي
ثلاثمائه الف منهم على الجبهه حسب وزنكوف
خطه كييف تمر عبر انهاء حرب المدفعيه
والخنادق الا ان دفاعها الجويه انهكته
معارك الشتاء والمقاتلات التي يسعى
زيلينسكي للحصول عليها من الغرب لم تصل
وثائق مسربه كشفت ما يقال داخل المكاتب
المغلقه
واشنطن لا تتوقعون نصرا حاسما للجيش
الاوكراني حتى وان دربته وسلحته
وبالنسبه لاوكرانيا القضيه اكبر بكثير من
مجرد نصر او هزيمه خيبه الامل هذه المره
ستجعل الحرب في اوكرانيا بلا موعد نهائي
ما يجعل النتائج رهن سيناريوهات مفتوحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات